and fire drills so if the fire alarm
goes off please leave the building in an
orderly fashion through the nearest fire
exit
please use either the fire exit through
the main doors of the hall or the fire
exit to the store room adjacent to the
stage
the fire assembly point is the island in
front of the main entrance to the
building
please do not delay your evacuation by
collecting your belongings
please do not return to the building
until given permission to do so by the
council staff
please note that the meeting will be
live streamed
please switch off your mobile phones and
turn or turn them to silent
please note that toilet and hand washing
facilities are in the foyer area
members of the public
while you're of course entitled to film
or take photographs during this meeting
can I please emphasize to you that this
should be done without disruption to the
meeting and can only be done from a
designated area in the public seating
can I please therefore ask you to raise
your hands clearly in the air if any of
you wish to take photographs or film
this evening
I can see no hands
just a brief note from myself
welcome members welcome members of the
public
this is my first seat as chairman on
this committee so please bear with me
I'll have
very experienced Mike
next to me and very experienced Sonia
next to me there I'm sure they're going
to keep me in line and give me a dig in
the ribs if I'm going off course
so bear with me
members your voice will only be captured
on the live stream when your microphone
is switched on
so please remember to switch on your
microphone when you're invited to speak
and switch off again when not speaking
again members voting will be done on a
show of hands in line with the
Constitution
I will ask for a show of hands four and
then against recommendations and we'll
also ask for a show of hands for those
wishing to abstain from voting
we can now kick off with our agenda item
one
there have been no apologies for absence
received
item two non-members attending
there doesn't appear to be any
item three
minutes of the meeting held on the 30th
August 2022.
all these minutes agreed members
I'll take that as agreed
item number four
to receive the Declarations of Interest
members are therefore are there any
Declarations of Interest
German uh just to cover himself a member
of Barney parish council member of Essex
County Council and also sit on the
planning committee at Essex County
Council
thank you Mike
yeah
thank you chairman yeah radio channel
Council
of course that is in case anything comes
up which may impinge okay
we said you have Council Newport
and obviously sorry obviously World
counselor for a rose Northern rural but
also I remember the planning committee
thank you
Council Newport thank you chairman um
member of Essex County Council and a
member of ready Town Council
thank you
agenda item number five new local plan
position statement
members Daniel Goodman will present the
officer's report over you Daniel
thank you chairman uh so members the new
local plan position statement has
essentially been put together to provide
members and other interested parties
with an update on the progress made
today on the new local plan I'm hoping
most of it will be familiar to you and I
don't intend to read the entire
um the entire thing but just cover the
main main aspects and then happy to take
any questions at the end so as members
will know the new local plan is being
developed over a plan period to 2040. it
will need to set a positive and
deliverable strategy for addressing
development needs over that period but
also make appropriate provision for
safeguarding enhancing and managing the
district's built historic and natural
environments
so since 2015 and I appreciate some
members on the committee have um been
there the the entire every step of the
way but since 2015 there's been a number
of substantial steps uh in the
progression of the new local plan
uh firstly an informal public engagement
exercise in 2016 which was undertaken at
the parish level
um call for science processes between
2015 and 2018 which allowed landowners
and other parties to put forward land
that they wish to consider or wished us
to consider
uh we undertake the issues and options
consultation in late 2017 into early
2018 which was a very high level
consultation on the challenges and
opportunities facing the future of the
district
um and then further consultation in 2021
called the spatial options consultation
which set out Geographic options for how
we could address certain development
needs
so also included in the note are two
tables one of which covers
evidence-based documents that are
substantially complete or complete some
of which have not yet been to the
committee but will in due course most of
which have however been to the committee
before
and then the second table is intended to
give members an indication of uh
evidence base that is currently being
worked on or recently complete and
hasn't yet made its way to the committee
um
this uh both tables set out kind of the
broad purpose of these documents
hopefully
um they cover most aspects that members
will agree are relevant to the new local
plan
so um just in terms of key
considerations and guiding principles so
um progress on the new local plan
um Beyond where we are now is likely to
include a few more steps so one of which
is a consultation we hope to undertake
called a preferred options which will
indicate what the council considers
should be in its final local plan
a further consultation on the very final
local plan
um and then obviously examination in
public whereby that new local plan as
submitted will need to be considered by
a government inspector who will test it
for its soundness and legal compliance
uh lastly members there are um some
paragraphs in this note around
um strategy matters and policy matters
um it does summarize uh the latest
position on strategy as included in the
spatial options consultation with a
commitment that the committee will
consider in due course options for
um taking those strategy options forward
or making changes as necessary and
similarly with the policy position
that's intended to include those
detailed planning application style
policies uh equally we intend to bring
an item back to a future committee date
where we can start to agree provisional
wording for those kinds of policies
so chairman I'll leave it there on the
position statement but I am very happy
to take any questions the members might
have about that item the recommendation
uh is that that document be noted
accountable please thank you chairman
uh I'm a little bit disappointed
that we're only looking at 2040. and the
reason I say that is that you know over
the last few years we have had
discussions when I was a portfolio
holder in regards to investment and the
need to look to longer term a 30-year
term if you remember the conversations
we had
and that is common sense in as much as
the conversation as I had as a member of
The Institute of Economic Development
was that anybody who wishes to invest in
this District needs to have the comfort
of having a longer time to understand
how the returns can come back
if the term is 30 years rather than 15
and I believe I was told and I think I
did mention to you that there is a bit
of hesitancy on investors and developers
in regards to infrastructure if it's not
a longer term and that's the main worry
I have I know that all of us around this
table as members have always said it has
to be infrastructure first before
anything else and to enable
infrastructure first
investment has to be guaranteed and that
guaranteed for any return needs to be at
least 30 years so I consider literally a
term of 15 years for a plan
short-termism in my opinion and I've
always voiced that term and you will you
will know that as well so for me I'm not
happy that we're looking at that also
the fact that we've extended the time so
now we're running into the period of uh
where the existing plan will now be
extinct
and it would be working with the new
plan coming forward in 2025
everything has gone back a year and
there's a bit of a risk here in my
opinion in it going back a year uh I
don't know if what is this due to that's
the most important question is this a
resource issue that is the problem is it
lack of the information you need to come
forward to make the plan in your
consideration sound when it comes to
inspection I will leave it there I think
that's quite a lot
I can come back
I'm sorry
yeah thank you for that Council award I
mean I think just as a point of clarity
over the plan period I think
fundamentally what we're looking at in
the new local plan is a vision to 2050
so a strategy that talks to revision to
2050 I think in terms of how National
policy talks it obviously talks about
plan periods and and the mppf talks to
15 years of a plan period
that doesn't mean that you can't
indicate what you what you want to do
after that 15 years has finished so I
think it's just a slight distinction
between having a long-term 30-year
Vision or whatever we might we might
call it versus then the specific plan
period that will be examined on because
an inspector won't examine us on a on a
30-year window they'll examin us on
whether or not it's sound over that 15
years so it's certainly not intended to
be a short-term plan
um we are expecting to have to update a
new local plan you know every five years
at least but um I agree with you on on
the principle that it needs to have a
long-term vision and strategy built into
it it's just that the plan period
element and the soundness checks relate
to 15 years from examination hence twins
25 to 2040. so I hope that satisfies um
that that question I think just in terms
of The Wider timetable and I'm conscious
that item
six is is talking more to the forward
program I think fundamentally the the
timetable and the program reflects
generally the time it takes to get the
evidence done which obviously is the key
aspect so as we'll get on to there are
key bits of evidence involved transport
assessment infrastructure delivery plan
that um just by their very nature take
take quite a while so
um in that sense
um on paper compared to the last local
development scheme it may appear that
there's been a slippage but I think
fundamentally we are still working to a
realistic timetable and it's just
reflective of the need to make sure that
evidence is in place before any
decisions are made
um rather than having trying to fit the
evidence to those decisions so hopefully
that satisfies you but I'm happy to come
back on the local development scheme
timetable when we get to that item if
that's okay
um
queries are around paragraph 3.24
which um
is talk about
some policy out of sync with the
national policy
and the examples you're you're giving
are around
um going to carbon zero biodiversity
better
design codes
um
I understand that Henry must and maybe
Marcus Hudson have been in touch with
you as well around this because
obviously now we've declared a climate
emergency
we are able to back up some of these
policies because of that Declaration of
climate emergency now where I've been
speaking to other councils which have
done the same and they've been in a
position where they're
climate emergency committee is also
looking at policies at the same time as
the local plans being developed it's
been quite useful to get
the climate committee to look at things
which can go into the local plan around
biodiversity maybe passive houses things
like that so is that something you will
be looking at and liaising with Henry
and Marx and obviously I'll just declare
for the
record I'm the lead member for climate
on the executive
yeah thank you Council Hawaii so
absolutely yes so we we do work closely
with Henry and now that he's in that
permanent post will obviously continue
to work um closely with him I think
we're building up not just in Rochford
but actually
um in the county and also just in the
country a much wider depth of evidence
now that supports um things like Net
Zero policies so if you go back even two
years it was nigh on impossible to get a
policy like that found sound because
most inspectors would say that that the
burden on the developer was too great
and it wasn't Justified there are now
councils in Cornwall Somerset who have
successfully argued those policies so
they've set the Benchmark really there's
pieces of work being done for the Essex
climate action commission um aligned
with Essex County Council that have kind
of proven that the viability argument
isn't really substantive in the sense
that it's marginal so that gives us a
good place to start and absolutely happy
to carry on working with Marcus and
Henry about that
a question about
whether or not there could be a role for
for that committee and everything else
I'm happy to take that away consider how
that might work obviously just making
sure that we're not duplicating but
actually kind of complimenting but
fundamentally if we're all working to
the same targets you know I'm sure that
that can only be a good thing
you can also stepped off okay thank you
John
um I'm going to pick up on some of the
things that Council Ward mentioned there
uh particularly around infrastructure
um and that is something I think is very
important because in encouraging
investment they need long-term
um
they need to have confidence for long
term
the one thing that worries me and I'll
be interested to know whether it
concerns you is we keep hearing from
central government they keep changing
the goal posts
are moving this and suggesting that and
what have you how are we kind of cope
with potential changes that may come
forward
um particularly if we have a change of
government in a year or so time
yes thank you for that councilor step
two so I think it's fair to say there's
been obviously a lot of consultations
white papers things like that
um on the future of the planning system
and I think um it's probably fair to say
that there's kind of two twin processes
running alongside one another so on the
one hand you've got changes that might
come through National planning policy
which are slightly light to touch less
disruptive but but also interesting to
us around
um how you might calculate housing need
for example which obviously is
fundamental to the plan
so and the other aspect is the leveling
up and regeneration bill which is making
its way through
um Parliament
um fairly slowly but getting there which
is looking to introduce a fairly
different distinct planning system from
around 2025 2026
um which obviously we're still a few
years off for now so I think my advice
has always been the same really which is
that
um for the time being we can only really
work to National policy as we know it
but it's it's a fair and reasonable
thing to do to have our eyes open to how
policy might change we're not at that
stage yet with a new local plan where
we're making binding decisions we're not
at the stage yet where we're shutting
down
um eventualities so in that sense there
will become a point almost like a
Gateway I suppose when we start looking
at the the final local plan which is
probably according to my local
development scheme probably in a year's
time around that time where clearly
we're going to have to take you know
take a temperature check and make sure
that we're happy with that but I I would
advise that obviously
um until we know what's actually going
to make its way International policy
I'll be quite candid to say that every
time a consultation comes out it's
different to the last and so there's not
really much weight that we can give to
that but I think it's fair to say that
you know we are alive to that and it
doesn't really change at the heart what
a new local plan will be doing or is
what it might change is
how much growth might be needed how you
know how much weight we should give to
Greenbelt versus other issues and that
will obviously be important by the time
we get to the final local plan but we're
at the moment I think all we can really
do is press on because actually the
risks of not pressing on are you know
equally severe when you think about
Planning by appeal and other things like
that so hopefully that's that helps
Council award
thank you chairman
um I'd like to come back on a couple of
points uh one that was made by Council
Ahoy with regard to 3.24
um I over the last three years as you
know I've been doing a considerable
amount of research into you know
um
how we can actually be self-sufficient
in first self-sufficient in energy and
various other things and those proposals
uh I have censored you have those and
I'd be happy if you would share those
with colleagues around this table so
they can also see the research that has
gone in to what I've what we've actually
looked at at what we can do and what it
is possible to do
um I think that's going to be very very
important and we'll answer a lot of the
questions and a lot of the issues that
Council Ahoy has brought up and I think
it ticks every single box that we've
been looking at and again I think it's
important that we actually try to focus
this somewhere into our local plan as as
part of what we're trying to do I think
as far as
counselor Steptoe mentioned about a new
government coming in and what they're
going to do that is our biggest concern
in my opinion is that is the unknowns
that are going to happen we don't know
what's going to happen but we do know
what happened
earlier on
before the conservative government came
in in 2010 where the housing numbers for
this District were set and I believe
somewhere in the region of about 23 000
and they were cut down
to
4260 which is the one we were working on
which was 285 per annum
so
for me
the incoming government and I'm sure it
will be an incoming socialist government
has almost vowed to make 335
000 homes a year that's the figure that
has been banded about not the three
hundred thousand and I would say that we
are going to be on the end this is what
does concern me because then I I'll
delay in not doing this local plan
sooner
that we may be on the end of something
that we don't want
and I would really want to look at
extreme urgency in getting our plan done
before the 2025 deadline that you've
actually got down there and I'd like to
know you know can we advance it a little
bit quicker
um to
try and avoid the higher allocations
that I believe are going to be imposed
on us and I wonder I'm sure the chairman
doesn't know yet
but could he give us a date a possible
earlier date for the preferred options
to go out for consultation
but I'll I'll doubt without giving an
earlier date at the moment
um off the cuff I mean if you look at
the amount of documentation that's still
to come in I know
um it's going to take What It Takes I
take your point but I think if you
speculating about what might happen in a
year and a half time and what policy
they may pursue I think that's a bit
speculative
albeit it might be right but it Israel's
respected we can't plan on that and but
in general I take your point if we can
push on and get our plan done quickly
the most valuable thing there for that
will be re reacting to the changes that
are already on their way through but not
well defined
um even this Monday we've got a complete
change of uh approach apparently from
Michael gove's announcement and so on so
we've got to be our react to all those
things if they do come through and hit
us and but in the short term we've got
to Crunch to transport assessment the
infrastructure space and all the other
aspects that have got to be done and
we've already got a tough plan
to achieve what we've got on the on the
plan
um so right off the cuff I don't see us
being able to give you a date we could
do it earlier maybe a little bit future
on if I could just come back I I do
respect your answer I'm I've been in
that place myself so I I do know and I
do understand
um I think what we need to actually be
looking at is
be willing to make it shorter because
the more advanced and I think uh both
Daniels will agree
that the more advanced we are in our
plans and our local plan the less likely
the government and its changes will
impact us now I'd like a view on that
but it is my opinion that I don't think
the more advanced we can be down the
road of our local plan the less chance
the government will interfere with us I
don't know what your opinion is on that
either of you
Daniel
yeah thank you chairman I think it's
quite hard to say but what I would say
is that
if you look at ways in which
um if you think about it in terms of
risks from not having an up-to-date
local plan
I don't think we're currently in an era
where there's much intervention in the
planning Authority directly that might
change under any government but that's
not necessarily the the pressing risk
the more
real risk I suppose is that if you're
not if you if you haven't been
delivering enough housing if you're not
projected to be delivering enough
housing then there is that risk that
usually in an appeal setting there may
be weight given to that fact and you
might end up with sites that you weren't
hoping for or what have you so it's true
to say that if you advance a local plan
then obviously it gives a stronger
indication of what it is the council is
looking to do and therefore the council
is better placed to resist the things it
doesn't want to happen and there are you
know there are things that can be done
around giving weight to a plan that's
Advanced but not yet adopted but I think
we're probably a little bit off that you
know we've still got quite some some
pressing stuff to do around strategy and
um and and policy before we get there so
I I don't think we're on you know we're
I don't think we're staring down a cliff
edge of of of problems but I think I
agree with your general point it would
be good to you know one of a better
phrase get on with the local plan
because it does put us in a better place
to manage risk and to make sure that you
know gen as a general rule the council
is a little bit more in control of its
its own destiny but I would agree really
with what council Crips has said that I
think the timetable for the preferred
options is already fairly uh fairly
challenging albeit you know deliverable
um
um at the kind of end of deliverable
shall we say it there may be
opportunities to condense
um onward stages of that and obviously
if there are changes to National policy
some of those are targeted at trying to
make it a bit easier and a bit less you
know
respectfully bureaucratic to demonstrate
that stuff so I think possibly that
might be something we can talk about in
a future committee meeting once this
first phase of work is is complete
please
thank you chairman um much of what I was
going to say on my first point has been
covered on this what might be
um the speculation about next year's
various Alternatives and one of course
might be a coalition
the lib Dems are talking about 380 000
per annum but the question I've got
around that is not based on the current
planning of the conservative government
to make targets advisory rather than
compulsory
is that likely to bring about reduction
in our prediction of what we would need
in Rochford District if that were to be
implemented
that's I've got two or three others if
it's all right so I'll wait for that
first okay
now that that's fine Council Foster I
think this is a this is an issue we're
going to have to Grapple with
um probably at the next committee or or
also fundamentally what we can't do is
have a closed mind to what housing need
might be so what what it appears that
the kind of recent consultations around
National policy are saying is that the
government methodology isn't mandatory
and and the door is open to a to an
alternative
but inspectors when they're looking at
that alternative are going to want to be
confident it's robust and obviously
they're likely to be give more scrutiny
to something that's coming in lower than
the government speaker than they might
be going higher and there are councils
out there that go for a higher figure
because they want to drive economic
growth or what have you so there is a
there's a the door is is slightly open
to considering if an alternative
assessment is Justified but it would
have to be justified and I think you
know that that probably means in some
way demographically showing that there's
a there's a suitable alternative figure
what we can't do like I say is have any
kind of
Fork you know conclusion going into that
work and then trying to generate a
figure that you know we've already
decided would you know we'd prefer so
um if it's okay I'll defer to probably
some of the meat of that for future
meeting other than to say
um you know
there's a there's an opportunity but it
has to be justified
sorry my mic that's all right carry on
should I run through all the questions
first or take them one at a time
um next one was about page 5.5 and the
subject of retail space which is
mentioned
um just a quick question really has it
bear in mind why in the world has
changed in the last few years with
online shopping and so on
um has that gone into an adjustment on
the retail space requirements for the
next local plan
uh question three my third question was
on page 5.4 table two
um and it's again about the transport
assessment the transport assessment is
planned for completion in November
and I think the preferred options uh
allocations is due about the same time
my my thought my question is around does
the transport assessment in any way
consider what might be built through the
plan or is it just transport assessment
on the situation as it stands at the
moment
my fourth point is just an observation
really uh on page 5.5 3.12 the
priorities I would like to see somewhere
in priorities a clear statement about
the priority of a Brownfield
contaminated and previously built sites
if I've missed it elsewhere in the thing
I do apologize
um
um yes and probably a different angle on
the numbers
um on page 5.5 3.14
I believe we have a housing waiting list
of more than a thousand and that's come
to me in various uh
ways through a couple of local issues
um just looking at the numbers assuming
the government Target of 360 per annum
and a policy of 35 affordable that would
equate about 126.
affordable which was about 101
rented and 25 affordable Buy
so really my question is and it's a big
question I think in the sense is it how
affordable percentage policy
adequate in light of the waiting list we
have
which I think is a thousand plus
um you know based on the the numbers
we've got on the targets that's 10 years
worth of um affordable housing so it
seems like a problem we've got to
somehow challenge
um and can we
can we influence a mix of houses in
developments because one of the things
that come to me quite clearly is local
residents who've got young families
aspiring to get into that onto the
housing ladder and the mix of houses
that would be a good first-time buys is
not a high percentage I believe
an end of questions and comments
because like
[Music]
thank you councilor Foster so um you'll
have to forgive me if I've forgotten or
get the order wrong um but just so
firstly just on the retail floor space
so we will bring the where that figure
has come from to this committee so
essentially it's a retail and Ledger
needs assessment update that was done
um uh around a month or so ago now we do
plan to bring um quite a bit of evidence
before the committee over the the Autumn
um it's based Loosely on a a model
um that essentially is built from a ton
of data that goes through some kind of
you know sausage machine and projects
forward as to the likely retail need per
person for example and then that's
aggregated up into a fairly rounded
assessment of what's likely to be did in
a specific area so that model
um it's it's an extension of what used
to be called the east of England
forecasting mods but essentially it's um
it's a similar thing
um that builds in
um kind of projected and current trends
in retail demand so no doubt if you run
the model today it will produce a lower
figure than it might have done 10 years
ago when perhaps there was more demand
it also takes into account
um the impacts of covid which have you
know basically accelerated clearly the
loss of a bit of retail so it is
um in that sense
um an up-to-date measure based on
current and expected Trends it's not um
kind of an archaic model that looks at
how things used to be but obviously we
can get into that when we bring the that
assessment
so in terms of local plan transport
assessments so fundamentally the first
stage of work is going to have two
elements which kind of encapsulate both
aspects of what you said so there is
that need for a kind of baselining
exercise and then there is also a need
to kind of consider
um what different options the impact
different options for growth would have
on the transport Network and how it
mitigation I.E you know new Junction New
Road whatever that might be could
alleviate some of that mitigation so
um that November day is when we expect
to have the very final report from that
options testing but there is going to
have to be a need for this committee to
inform the options that go into that to
be tested and naturally there will be
outcomes of that work that arrive before
the final glossy report which means that
we can be reporting to the committee and
talking about preferred options so it
shouldn't be the case that that report
lands and then we have to come to the
committee to start talking to you for
the first time about preferred option
there should be a bit more synchronicity
it's just obviously like to bring you
know for one of the better phrases the
kind of final glossy report to the
committee and that's that date
essentially in that report it is
obviously quite tire but you know we're
being kind of
um
not ambitious but we're hoping to kind
of make a substantive process progress
reflecting what council Ward said
um
in terms of strategic priorities I I
think
um what I didn't do was list out
um the whole range of what's under these
which is strategic objectives So within
those shooting objectives you will find
things around Brownfield prioritization
and that is that is kind of been
captured in quite a lot of what we've
done with the local plan today so those
priorities are a little bit more high
level kind of just existing as
categories if you like
um in terms of the housing need and
relationship affordable housing I mean
what you will find is in Rochford and in
lots of places if you are to if you work
it out as a percentage you could make a
case to say that probably over half of
the houses that need to be built in an
area would need to be affordable 10
years in order to meet demand in full
that's not uncommon
um what we are constrained by in terms
of local plans and planning applications
is obviously we will have to demonstrate
for the local plan that our affordable
housing policy doesn't render
development unviable
um and so 35 which is the current policy
is essentially that compromise as of
2011 when that 2011 to 2014 when that
when those documents were were
progressed what we will have to do for
the new local plans consider the case
for a higher percentage
clearly that high percentage has to be
weighed against that viability thing
because that's what an inspector is
going to do
we may be able to to achieve a 40 45
policy we'll obviously have to review
the the housing mix within that tenure
between rent and shared ownership Etc
but there is just that we don't have
complete autonomy if you like over that
percentage
um but obviously totally totally totally
take that point on that you said lastly
just on housing mix I mean yes the new
local plan will have to have a policy
which talks to the appropriate housing
mix on sites typically it's still a
matter for negotiation at planning
application stage but we can certainly
give an indication of what we think an
appropriate mix is likely to be whether
that's types of home or number of
bedrooms Etc we do already have a policy
that does that but it's like I say there
is that element of negotiation on
individual planning applications
um so it's um I would say it's also
informed by kind of contemporaneous
um liaison with say our council's
housing team for example who might say
that policy slightly out of date now so
um hopefully that's helpful
thanks chairman the one phrase that
worries me more than anything else with
a local plan
it's a simple phrase that says Don't
duty to cooperate
worries me more than anything else
particularly in the southern areas
particularly out towards the east where
South End has very little space to
actually move they may not look to us
for
housing but they could be looking to us
for infrastructure to relieve their
housing problem
how much weight
do we have to give with
due to cooperate and how much can we
how much feedback can we put into it to
control the amount that South End for
example could come forward with
yeah thank you councilor step two so I
think the fundamental thing to say a
star is obviously a local plan in
Rochford for example can only set
policies and strategy for rocks really
can't bind and you know before it's do
anything and vice versa enabling
Authority can't bind and what should
plan to do anything for the time being
due to cooperate remains in law
um I think it's probably my catchphrase
but it isn't necessarily a duty to agree
but you have to obviously work
collaboratively with
um other public sector Partners to to
kind of agree and try and Forge A Way
Forward
um where you can that's not to say that
you know you can be bound into doing
something that is you know let's say in
the planning context it's just not
sustainable to do so I think what I
would say on the strategy level is that
the strategy the watch for local plan is
for Rochford Council and sales as
counselors to decide the duty cooperate
exists to help us work with those
neighboring authorities and others to
try and work out if there are
opportunities to do stuff that is better
or or to link things up and there are
positives that can come out of that
obviously you don't want to be both you
know you and a neighboring Council
planning for something and then you
don't talk to one another and then you
find that you've both built the road you
know it's half kilometer apart or what
have you so there is that Advantage the
only thing I would say is that obviously
part of the government consultations is
suggesting that you property will be
replaced with a less binding
um policy test around alignment so I
expect that probably will come into the
four in the next six months or so and I
would guess that that will be more about
showing to an inspector that one has
acted reasonably and that you've aligned
where you can rather than the kind of
you to cooperate legal test which some
plans were basically being thrown out on
the first day of examination because
they hadn't met
um so there is it does look like the
British operate will be replaced
um but I would just reassure you that
obviously it is rochford's plan we're
talking about and it's Council to
determine what goes in it
and we're writing assuming that councils
such as South End perch Chelmsford basil
and will have the right of consultation
with our plan
yes so absolutely so whenever anyone
goes out on a formal consultation
um we often nearly always respond if
it's neighboring Authority likewise
neighboring authorities can respond to
us so that's if you like the formal
level of Engagement but obviously you
can imagine an officer level there's
lots of informal engagement around all
kinds of planning issues
um that we can report to the committee
as and when obviously it relates to the
new local plan
Council award thank you very much
chairman
um there was a kind of interesting point
the councilor Foster brought up which
I'd like to explore if I may
um it goes from three-pointers on page
5.5 and it goes 3.12 it's going to be
3.13 and 3.14 if I can just take those
as they go
um we've got our five strategic
priorities which are down there now a
couple of those yes are within our
control
but there are quite a few that are
totally outside of our control where
we're going to have to kind of make some
kind of partnership or some kind of
arrangement with with those people and
those providers to making things and I'm
I'm looking at strategic priority four
which sort of hits me which is
sufficient provision of Health
I think one of the big problems as far
as that is concerned is that it's
outside of our remake completely no
matter what we do it's going to be down
to the county to decide and I guess
education is exactly the same no matter
what we do we can provide a spot
for it but it doesn't necessarily mean
that the county or NHS will take that
spot up and what happens and what always
happens is that
us as counselors are blamed by the
residents basically because hang on a
second this was supposed to be provided
and it isn't and it's not in our remit
to be able to do that we have provided
the spot that it can go on but it's not
down to us to actually fill that spot in
and I think that's something that needs
to be highlighted you know the whole way
through whatever we're doing to ensure
that members the public our residents
understand how limited some of our
remits are in doing this plan
and going on from that an interesting
point that um councilor Foster made in
regards to the actual numbers now I do
have a problem with both 13 313 and 314.
and at the very end of 314 I think the
last bit this equates to a need for
around
6500 additional homes by 2040 whilst use
of this method is not mandatory use of
an alternative method requires
exceptional justification well I think
we do have that exceptional
justification provided by the government
is their own figures in both the ons and
the census because the ons definitively
shows that births are going down and
deaths are going up so we're having a
squeezing
of the demographic around the country
and here and the census well that
actually made a total nonsense of the
modeling that they did for that period
of 2011 2021 where they got the growth
completely wrong it was a lot lower than
the modeling so I mean I would be
challenging wanting to challenge the
government very very
robustly
using their own evidence against any
modeling they wish to put in place now
I'd like a view on that from yourselves
please
[Music]
yeah thank you Council Ward so I mean in
terms of that priority I know where you
say that you know health is the room at
the NHS and some matters remember this
against cancer Council I think there's
there are things we can do in the local
plan that make good outcomes for those
things more likely we don't have
absolute control and obviously that's
something we're going to have to ponder
at every stage I think obviously those
priorities reflect Ambitions so in a
sense we don't want the Ambitions to
read negatively but I take what you say
and I think you know it's a fair comment
that we'll have to ponder as we develop
the strategy I think just in terms of
the housing numbers and I think to be
honest it's probably something we should
discuss in a future meeting you know in
in The Wider picture
um you know fundamentally I think there
is there is quite a lot of concern
across the country about whether or not
the demographics of the government's
method are valid or not
um I think we can we can have that
discussion the only thing I would say is
for better or worse I think the
government have set a very High bar to
meet and actually
there's probably more of a conversation
around thinking about whether or not we
can sustainably meet that number what we
might need in terms of infrastructure in
order to be able to meet that number
that might be
a a more fruitful kind of debate because
there is
like I say a very high bar to convince
an inspector that the method is is
flawed it might soften because obviously
the government is saying is reiterated
that it's a mandatory figure so there
might be cases where it gets challenged
and then sets of precedent for the time
being I would say that bar as far as I
can see remains very high and it's a
cause of lots of plans being found
unsound
um where they where they propose to to
build fewer homes so
um hopefully that that covers your
questions
don't remember as any other questions
no okay
sorry chairman
um just one and maybe I'm being a bit
stupid here at the numbers this period
is from 2025 to 2040 right
correct
so those figures I think are more
reflecting the need from now but you're
right at the point of the plan being
examined it will need to demonstrate 15
years which will be 25 to 20 40. so
um if you like it's 15 times 360 at the
point of the plan being found just 5400.
if you take off the numbers that are
needed between now and then you may well
be right I probably can't do that mental
mess
okay uh at the end of 5.1
there's one recommendation set out in
5.1 of the report
that the planning policy committee notes
the new local plan position statement
members is that noted
thank you
we push on
item number six local development scheme
22 25
again I hand over to Dan Goodman to
present the officer's report on that one
thank you chairman uh so members the
local development scheme is a formal
document that the council is obliged to
prepare which essentially sets out a
forward program and timetable for its
local plan uh and any other statutory
planning documents such as supplementary
planning documents for example
um so the last local development scheme
was adopted around the same time spatial
options consultation I think as we've
touched upon it predicted a preferred
options got station sooner than now so
clearly there is a need to set a new
local development scheme which sets um a
more up-to-date timetable
uh so there is
um essentially a table which sets out
the timetable for the new local plan
um it envisages of preferred options
consultation this winter I think if you
look at the other appendix we've
indicated that's likely to be early next
year
um and then further stages in Winter
2024 and then ultimately submitting
um in 2025 for examination clearly this
is the kind of document that you do need
to review regularly to make sure it
remains up to date so there may be a
need to review this in a subsequent
committee meeting but this is the
timetable that is being recommended to
members at this time I think as I've
said it is quite an ambitious timetable
but it's one that I think we feel is at
the end of being deliverable whilst also
managing some of those risks that we've
spoken about around not having an
Upstate local plan
um
there is also at appendix B I believe a
kind of Gantt chart which um appreciates
a little bit
um of a visual mess but hopefully the
principle is clear around how some of
the subtasks are likely to progress over
that period we've only done it in detail
up to the preferred options consultation
obviously we will keep this kind of
document up to date something we have
tried to demonstrate is the
interdependency between some of the
evidence
um clearly there are matters such as
local plan transport assessment and
infrastructure delivery plan that need
some kind of indication of what we want
to test
and there's obviously a relationship
between essentially plugging the outputs
of one into the into the other and so on
hence why there are some arrows pointing
between different rows on the Gantt
chart
uh so I'll stop there members the
recommendations I believe are that the
local development scheme itself be
recommended to council for adoption and
that appendix B I believe it is the
Gantt chart be noted thank you
Council
yes uh thank you chairman I wasn't sure
where to raise this either in
the minutes of the previous meeting or
on this item because it's the only other
place where it's mentioned on the
offended Quay I think that is we've got
on the first section
complete evidence
the bottom one is open space is study
it says complete it's in complete
evidence however at the last meeting
this was sent back for additional work
and we haven't seen it in this committee
at all yet so I'm not sure it can be
complete if we've not agreed it yet that
was the main question
yeah thank you uh Council Hawaii so
essentially those updates have been made
it is still Our intention to bring it
back to the committee I think what we
wanted to do is bring essentially quite
a bit of not necessarily quite a bit but
a bit of evidence to the next committee
so that we can talk about it in the
round so it will come back to this
committee we've labeled it as Complete
because we've made those updates but
we're not saying that it doesn't need to
come back or that essentially it's
published because it's not so
um I'm happy for it to be moved into
emerging evidence until such time as the
committee gets to consider it but I'm
just to assure you we are aware that
obviously those comments were made last
time and that they need um needs to come
back to the committee
councilworld
thank you chairman
um I have an issue with the Brownfield
register
um obviously we've got this on the
agenda later on
but I'd like to give notice that I would
actually like that particular item
deferred completely in its entirety
because I'm not happy with it at all
um maybe we leave it until that is part
of the agenda but unfortunately it comes
up on 6B as being complete and I cannot
agree to it being complete
okay I hear what you say uh Daniel
I think we probably ought to deal with
it at the item on the agenda sorry I
feel like we should probably deal with
it when we get to that item on the
agenda if that's okay I agree I think
it's on the agenda and we have that
opportunity I don't want to disrupt this
particular item we're on at the moment
so let's clear that
I know your point you're not going to go
along with the recommendation to adopt
that because of that so you you've made
that point
like
sorry just to clarify them because
I agree with Council Waldon that item
so that means because it's on appendix B
I'd have problems accepting appendix B
um well I I maintain that we've got if
you choose not to go along with that
we'll recall the uh the reception to
this recommendation that you turn and
then we'll deal with it in detail when
we get to it yep
uh would like to speak
okay
so let's go for it then item one
um there are two recommendations set out
on page 6.1 of report the first one
number one that the planning policy
committee notes the proposed program
plane plan set out appendix B
so we already know chat sorry chairman
um is councilor water going to move an
amendment to that
recommendation then to report
just in case
if I may come in German
um at this moment it would seem as if
we're putting the cart before the horse
on this we're recommending something or
going to recommend something that I
can't support at this moment in its
entirety
you know you'll notice apart from that
yep I'm happy to do that just to get
clicked just to get clear so the
Brownfield reference in appendix B is
what you object to correct times two yes
okay so you can agree other than those
that particularly yeah
[Music]
in the minutes if that's okay
I can't advise that you should move the
formal Amendment and then we'll record
it that way
okay so you've got to come up with the
words
a chairman if it assists um would you
like to move something along the lines
of
um that the planning policy committee
notes the proposed program plan with the
exception of the uh Brownfield register
set out to appendix B
I
okay so Council Ward you're proposing
that yes counselor presumably
is that correct yes
okay
so now we go back to the same question
again
oh sorry
I told you I was learning tonight
okay we need to vote on that Amendment
please
all those in favor four
that's you know
you know any against
you know
sorry
I'm sorry
hello
thank you it's a new unanimous decision
thank you
that's Apple noted
the second item
that the planning policy committee
recommends to full Council that the
local development scheme
2023 to 2025 attached the appendix day
be adopted and published on the
council's website
do I have a second after that
reductively
okay all those members in favor can you
please raise your hands
unanimous I'll get in there
thank you members
[Music]
you push onto item agenda number seven
new local plan spatial options
regulation 18 consultation feedback
report
members Daniel cuddler will present the
officer's report
so champ I may ask a question on this
item before the reports presented it may
save time okay
thank you and I'm sure
this is going to be um aware of this as
well
um this was again another item that was
referred
back
to
County policy policy for um some changes
particularly around the
further analysis on the 141 other
responses
um
I'm really sorry I've read this report
twice and I cannot see the 141 other
being analyzed at all
so it looks identical to the report we
had in August to me I may be wrong
because it's very long report and I've
read it twice and your eyes go blurry
but I just wanted to ask that question
has this taken account of those that
that work which was required which again
is minuted
on the minutes of the meeting of 30th of
August
um members expressed concerns with a
report on the ground so it failed to
include sufficient evidence and Analysis
councilor Emma Hoy moved a motion and
secondly by councilor J.E Newport that
the report be referred back to planning
policy for additional analysis and that
analysis was around the other for
140. in addition to that I did contact
uh Mr Goodman after that meeting because
it had been pointed out to me which I've
missed that the appendix are completely
missing hold Bridge
as an item and I cannot again find
holbridge in this report either so
they're just as success it may be Mr was
going to address those issues anyway but
I just wanted to make it easier for him
to address those
before
tell me you don't want to come back on
that
um thank you councilor Hawaii for
raising that
um
I uh I I I would say that I I have put
in the breakdown there of those 141
others
um and um yeah I will have to have to
draw those out
just a minute done the other day and
wants to expect
I was just going to say for Council I
always benefit I think
um
possibly on page 7.60 but possibly
elsewhere as well there is a bit more of
a breakdown on other in that section and
just in terms of the whole Bridge Parish
counts or response that is included
um in that in the long-form table
um at page
7.101 onto page 7.102 I think possibly
there was also
um Barling Parish Council possibly
suffered a similar fate in terms of
their response not being included so
this is the report as amended to reflect
what members requested so
um hopefully that break breakdown and
that information is in there but I
appreciate it's a bit of a tone and the
Amendments only reflect a small
percentage of that tone if you like but
I'll pass back to Mr goodler now
like uh down has identified the whole
Bridge paragraphs there which should
take you to the information and
previously you did 760
where has other work been done
so I'm not sure whether you've given the
size of this you want to be reading
right through it right now but
sorry
Mr Goodman and Mr could I want to
continue
please
um is it is it helpful to just you know
start with what I was going to do or to
to refer Council Hawaii to the um
um yeah good evening everyone so I'm
here to present on the feedback report
for spatial options consultation um this
consultation originally took place uh
between the 28th of July and 21st of
September 2021
um to recap this consultation form the
um second formal stage in the
preparation of Russia District's new
local plan following on from the issues
and options consultation back in 2018.
it says out a range of challenges and
opportunities related to how Russia
District could change and grow over the
next 20 years and the main focus was the
spatial or Geographic aspects I
presented a series of broad location
options with distribution of proposed
development sites across the district to
meet our Housing Development series
needs over the plan period
it also presented options across a range
of spatial themes which included
providing different types of housing for
different people combating climate
change supporting vibrant Town centers
or delivering the right infrastructure
to benefit residents and mitigate
impacts of development
another aspect was a range of visions
and different options for this key
settlements seeking feedback from locals
on these
it was a chance of residents businesses
land owners and other stakeholders to
give their views on policy priorities
spatial strategies and issues around
local communities and prospective site
allocations based on the latest context
um some of you may remember this item
from the 30th 30th of August
um it's just worth and and obviously
everyone does just worth pointing out
um that's I think in the um the the
context in the committee paper it refers
to the 30th of August 2023 and just a
note it should be the 2022 title there
we don't have a time machine after
feedback from the committee on that day
the item was taken away and a couple of
amendments were made
um firstly
um the additions relating to additional
detail requested on Headline finding two
and spatial strategy options to provide
a more detailed breakdown of the types
of responses categorized as other and a
summary can be found in the relevant
paragraph in this report which is 5.10
secondly the summaries of
representations by holbridge Parish
Council and also to note um on further
reflection we found barley Magnolia
Parish Council which had been admitted
from appendix 3 of the initial reports
they have now been summarized in the
relevant section of the reports it is
important to underline that these
representations were still recorded at
the time of the consultation and it was
just a matter of inclusion in in the
documents
um the original report was presented at
the August committee last year and the
amended reports was presented alongside
the PowerPoint presentation as a
briefing to all members in March so in
the interest of time I won't go into the
full breakdown of the the various key
headlines tonight
um it is however worth briefly noting
that the consultation tracks is
1536 unique responses which represented
at least 1 814 respondents but likely
far more because that's where people
indicated the number of um people within
the household these submissions totaled
6839 individual responses to questions
within the documents
um some of the key headline findings
from the consultation include is a
breakdown of the views on the spatial
strategy options presented by the paper
a prevailing concern about the capacity
of current infrastructure and calls for
an infrastructure first approach in the
local plan
um General concerns about over
development and impacts upon the green
belt and finally
um a concern about climate change and
environmental impacts and strong support
for a range of measures to mitigate
against these
so in conclusion I hope this gives a
good representation of the wide range of
feedback received from the public and
other stakeholders and consultees during
the consultation there is an awful lot
more in the full report and it certainly
does go on but that does include
summaries of all the key statutory
respondents some of these responses by
each theme in question and the key
issues facing each settlement in the
district according to respondents
um happy to take any feedback or
questions on board and happy to provide
answers
um
thank you
thank you chairman thank you Daniel Dan
um
we've seen this report before so I won't
go into the detail of it but just a
polite request that if um we do send
reports back would it be possible to
receive them when we receive the amended
reports we've tracked changes on so that
we can actually see what has changed in
those reports that just make
it easier is that okay yes very happy to
say that on board thank you
Council stepped off
thank you chairman I'm just picking up
on the Amendments can I refer you to
page seven nine zero seven point nine
zero
how do you find it
yeah
okay it's a bit there about Barling
Magna Parish Council uh in the next
heading box you've got Sutton and
Stonebridge Sutton is not part of Barney
manga Parish Council
so I think there's a slight uh miscreant
there because you have got Sutton Parish
Council listed on page 7.115
um yeah counselor if I may
um that's that's where
um so in the document there were a
series of um well
the Thematic presentations on the
different settlements and different
needs of those settlements and views on
proposals around those settlements and I
think the um there was a series of sites
presented in the Sutton and Stonebridge
section which barley Magnum Parish
Council felt compelled to respond on
because I think it's just where the you
know the boundary between wakerings and
Barling and and Sutton obviously there
are some quite large sites being
promoted for development there and
barley Magnum Parish Council felt it you
know that they they had views they
wanted to to have represented you know
on those sites just just um sort of a
little bit further away okay
Council Hawaii
just point out where the extra analysis
on Earth 1420 is because I I know he
said numbers I've now worked out the
numbering and I can't find it I know
I've read it so I'm sure I've read the
additional analysis but when I'm
comparing documents I can't see the
difference
thank you councilor Hawaii um which
obviously I'll just goes back to what um
councilor Newport saying when we get
doctors like this they're large we do
read them and it it's just it saves a
lot of time if we can see where the
changes have been made
thank you Council Hawaii and that that
is a fair point about
um track changes and we'll Endeavor to
take that on board in the future and
highlight you know where Amendments have
been made if I may um so on Page 7.60 in
um in the committee papers
um and if you look there so you've got
table seven then you've got paragraph
5.10
um the largest single preference
indicator was out of other attracting
141 preferences
um the following uh paragraphs
[Music]
5.1121314 are
um other ones which break down so the
other was a very broad category and
within that there were a range of views
so these are seeking to sort of draw out
the key the key responses within that
and and obviously it's
uh yes
well um
yes that's correct
I apologize for that so the census I
just read was the largest single
preference indicators was that of other
it's not though because I'm reading from
the August 22. good Paul
uh that's actually the paragraphs below
there uh the negative development
infrastructure paragraph 5.11 no
development paragraph 5.12
infrastructure first
we're asking for additional work this
I'm reading from the August 22 report
there
and I said it's not done but is it
somewhere else
or does that need to be clarified the
work we wanted
I think if I may cancel away I think
possibly the lack of track changes
aren't helping in in that sense we're
confident in that we know we did the
work that some more analysis in was in
there I think what I would say about
that breakdown is that obviously other
represented quite a lot of qualitative
views it wasn't really the kind of thing
you could quantify because obviously
people are making slightly different
points so in that sense there's probably
not any
meaningful statistical breakdown we can
do but I'm more than happy
um to
um prior to publishing this report to
consider whether or not there's some
more qualitative analysis we can draw
out
um or clarify where additional text
might be but it
I believe there there is a bit more of a
breakdown in that report
absolutely
so does that mean there are no changes
in relation to other 141 from the August
22 report to the report we're seeing
today
it might be you I'm prepared to
go forward with this report on the basis
that we receive a report tracked changes
before it's published
I mean what I would what I might suggest
then is that if members are generally
happy with this report we can clarify
if and where there are additional
um paragraphs reflecting that specific
request
and if there is any other qualitative
analysis we can draw out I'm happy
that we take away the commitment that we
will do that
um
like I say I think there's a slight
limit to how much we can statistically
break it down but we can we can look at
that I think
um In fairness I think
we probably thought that that was the
added analysis but that's not to say uh
that when we made those changes which
um In fairness were quite close to the
August committee last year that there
weren't other changes so I think
possibly the best thing is for us to
clarify that but if if um if counselors
are generally happy with the rest of the
report I think we can probably deal with
that in a kind of
um prior to publication sense
I'm certainly happy to to go back into
that and clarify and make sure we um
yeah we provide as much detail as we as
we have on that
Mike
councilman Newport secular donations
we've gone a slightly out of sync
because I was giving you the option to
accept what Dan was saying or not
because
councilor Newport looks like he's got a
relative point to make to what we're
talking about so Council award uh
newborn
thank you chairman
um
so
I don't really want to defer this item
again
um well maybe we could just put an
amendment into the recommendation that
what Daniel is proposing that prior to
publication
we received the document with
the track changes it was that what you
were saying Daniel
yeah I mean I'm happy that we go away
and check that and if and if there is a
bit more
that we could have said that I'm happy
to include that in a document to be
circulated because I think I might be
wrong but I think we're probably happy
with 99 of the document so I'm happy to
take that away
um obviously if members are happy to
table amendment to that motion then we
will we're happy to commit to doing that
um so Mike if you're happy with that
I do not want to delay this anymore but
we need to no but James had a way of
recording it so that it is formally
recorded did you get that
so I think I think members um
it's the it's the it's the
recommendation but you're including
um wording along the lines the the
approximate lines of um prior to
publication the committee members
receiving uh the document with track
changes uh which which clearly show the
changes from you know that have been
made since the year since the previous
iteration and uh you know where where if
if necessary
um including any additional their
information around those those 141 nerve
responses okay
I'm chewing is everybody happy with that
approach to recording it formally yeah
okay I'll go back to council wardy one
yeah just to follow on just on that item
I've got another one
um but as far as I could understand I
remember being at some of these uh
meetings some of the uh some of the
things but there were people there who
were actually saying well I don't agree
with anything that's here and I think
they must be the others uh literally
they didn't agree with anything any
option whatsoever you know and they were
there they had to be recorded and I
would guess that realistically when I
thought everything that was put in front
of them was nonsense so you know as far
as that was concerned how else do you
put it other
that that's my my view on what I saw
actually while I was there so I can only
put that in but the point I do want to
come to is actually on 7.93
um I'd like a comment actually on
Chelmsford City Council
and uh and how they are praise what we
should be doing with our numbers I I'd
like some sort of feedback uh from
either Daniel actually
sorry and I'm reading it um reading it
fresh now
consultation was coming up for two years
two years ago
um
is it in regard to the first line in
that table around yeah so in that
consultation it's worth saying that we
presented options
um
I'll say inequal options around how much
development should be accommodated in
the district
one of those options was to meet the
identified housing need as per the
government's method and one of those
options was to meet another 50 on top of
that and I think we don't need to get
into the pros and cons of that now but
clearly there are some cons
um so
I don't know whether to read that as
that's an endorsement of going with a
higher figure I imagine that's probably
not what's intended I think most likely
response was more intended just to
acknowledge that that is the
mathematical outcome of doing something
rather than endorsing an approach
um it would certainly be quite bold if
that was the reading they intended so I
don't think there's anything
particularly
um
concerning in that line in that table
okay
any more speakers members
there are two recommendations on 7.1
number one is that the committee
resolves to note the spatial options
feedback report at appendix a which
we've already discussed is going to be
covered by
as amended as
dirt um sorry
as
amended Okay so
I'll be happy to note it with that
codasil on there yeah okay
I'll move to the second recommendation
number two
that the committee result to consider
its findings and recommendations when
preparing for a subsequent phases of the
new local plan
do I have a second difference
foreign
all those in favor please shut your
hands
that's unanimous
we move on to item eight Brownfield land
register 2023 update
members Daniel Goodman will present the
officers report
thank you chairman uh so this report
consists of the 2023 update to the
council's Brownfield land register so as
members may be aware preparing at
Brownfield land register is a legal
requirement of the housing and planning
act and there are certain regulations
laid down which specify
um what sites or types of land are
eligible to be included
um it's worth saying that the council is
prepared
um numerous around for registers in the
past I think typically those haven't
come to the planning policy committee
but I think we now feel that this is
probably the more more appropriate forum
for them
um essentially uh this forms an update
so there are some sites removed which
typically the reason is because they're
fully built out and so there's no point
counting them um towards Brown for
capacity anymore and there have been
some sites added which perhaps either
have a new planning permission
um or which have been newly identified
so I I don't want to necessarily get
through the eligibility criteria at
length other than to say that the
regulations are quite
um specific and so they are fairly clear
about what types of land can and can't
be
um included in summary
um sites have to meet the national
policy definition of previously
developed land which is included at
paragraph 3.3 they have to be at least
0.25 hectares in size or capable of
meeting five or more houses
they need to be considered suitable for
residential development which is a
judgment you know ultimately I think
quite a few of the sites on here have
planning permission and therefore that
judgment's already been made but clearly
there's a judgment element to that they
have to be considered likely to be
available for residential development
which um typically means whether they
have planning permission or they've been
submitted through the corporate sites
and they have to be considered likely
achievable for residential development
which is more a case of
um is there any information to say that
they are not achievable um because um
clearly we don't have the detailed
liability information to judge all of
these sites
so um in the report at Pages 8.2 and 8.3
it goes into some detail taken from the
regulations around
um essentially the wording of how those
tests are applied
as it says at paragraph 3.9 in total the
brownford land roster 2023 identifies
total of 32 sites meeting the criteria
for inclusion that have a minimum
capacity of 839 dwellings and this
represents a 19 increase on the previous
update
um and there is a bit of a breakdown at
paragraph 3.10 around the likely windows
for delivery of those sites which um to
put it simply I mean if a site is small
and has planned permission now it's more
likely to be delivered sooner there are
clearly some sites in this register
which are likely to be years in the
making and hence they aren't included in
that window there's also an interactive
map of the register which is capable of
being updated independently off the
registered document itself and the
um
the intention with that is clearly to be
quite clear around where sites are on
the register and um so that that could
be accessed by the public and others
um so that is probably where I'll leave
it chairman I think the recommendation
is the Brownfield enrich to be noted and
obviously after noting we would intend
to publish it on the council's website
thank you
because her Steptoe
thank you chairman
um
it would be useful to be able to look at
the chart at the the end uh was it
appendix the end there 8.17 to know
which ones are now new on the list that
would have been an idea ideally
I'll be honest to say I've had struggle
reading this because on the computer
screen
it's it chops it in half and it makes it
difficult to follow it through so I
would like speaking personally
um a better printed copy so I can study
it a little bit more closely if that is
possible please
um I certainly having trouble reading
this the print is far too small for me
to actually read it easily
a couple of questions I'd like to ask
though is
how much work has been looked at on the
council's asset register with a view to
Brownfield sites and how many of those
have been identified as potential sites
that could be go forward
and also as well clarification on some
sites I can think of one particular site
which was greenhouses
was used commercially as a retail unit
but is now clear
of any structures other than a little
bit of footings
is that classified as Brownfield where
does that sit within the classifications
and I've also had a couple of people
point out to me where a couple of sites
which are completely unused at the
moment it used to have a building on it
but the building's long since
disappeared whether that could be
considered either as pre-developed or
Brownfield site
yeah thank you Council Hoy so at
appendix a which is part of the appendix
to the document
oh okay
and oh sorry did I misnavy apologies uh
sorry cancel step two
um
table three of appendix a does include
the sites that have been removed and the
sites that have been added I appreciate
that the printed copy that it is quite
small I think it's one of those we're
prescribed a number of columns that have
to be in the register and it's not
really practice practicable to um fit
them on a page of A4
um so so not a problem per se um but but
at table two and three there are
um those deletions and additions I think
on the point about the council's asset
register and actually the point The
Wider point you made about certain sites
I think the key test is that they have
to be to our knowledge available for
development and so there are some
Council on sites on here which have
planning permission for redevelopment
and so in that sense you know we we
reasonably expect that they're available
for development because they have a
planning permission
where a site doesn't have a planning
permission and it's on the asset
register I think you know we until such
time as an indication it is available
for development we can't really include
it and so in that sense there may well
be
more brownford science that as these
things get as this thing gets reviewed
you know it gets more and more sites
added to it and that's not just
canceling sites that might be the sites
you're referring to but if they haven't
applied for planning permission and they
haven't come through the call for sites
and we haven't got the landowner on the
phone telling us that they're available
it's really difficult for us to
determine they are available and if
they're not clearly available then it
can lead to misleading conclusions about
Brownfield capacity because if a site's
not available it's not going to come
forward so that's that restricts us in a
sense to only sites that we know to be
available
um and you know we we haven't been
advised by colleagues at the council
that a further list sites is or isn't
available and so in that sense we can't
really
um take anything like that into account
um so so that's what I would say about
that I mean we're happy to consider
other sites as part of reviews it's not
a problem but it's just like I say
unless they've got a planning permission
are allocated in the local plan or have
come from the call for sites it's really
tough for us to say that they're
eligible and obviously it could be
misleading if we put them in there and
they aren't available you know the
landowner May well ring us up and and
ask about that so hopefully that
clarifies I think what we have discussed
in the past and this is broader than
just a brownford land register which is
like I say very restricted by
regulations is whether or not there's an
ongoing exercise that we need to do
around
theorizing the capacity of other ground
food Land that isn't currently known to
be available and whether that's a
workflow exercise for us to bring to the
committee but that like I say that
wouldn't at the moment be compatible
with these specific regulations
for my chairman that's exactly what I
was going to go on to say I think that
would be very useful to have
Council
thank you chairman well as I've
mentioned before
I'm going to be asking for this item to
be moved for you further
now I don't want to go into site
specifics but I have
believe I've accounted for
1012 units which are not
on this Brownfield register that's
1012 units that is not on this register
so I would like to ask the chairman if
we can go for deferment to set up a
working party as soon as possible to go
through the items which I would like to
bring to that working party to show and
I think
councilor Steptoe has sung to add to
that as well as I'm sure probably as you
mentioned to councilman hoihime
yeah so I I feel that this before I can
accept this report I think in the light
of what we're needing to do in doing our
policy or Brownfield sites before we
look at any Greenbelt we need to be sure
of every Brownfield Park Brownfield and
contaminated site that can come forward
so we understand what we're dealing with
in regards to housing numbers and what
we need to do so that's what I'm asking
to move this evening
can you explain the source of your
information yeah this Source has been
readily available it's been provided uh
to Daniel Goodman they've had that
Source I've got it in front of me I have
seen all the sources that have come in
in regards to this over a period of a
year or two and I've asked for them to
be put on the register and they haven't
been put on that register so at this
moment I know where they are I can give
proof of them but I think it's unfair at
this time in the public domain at this
moment to name those sites
then I think I need you to respond to
that one I mean I suppose all I can say
is that this is our assessment of what
meets the regulations and I suppose you
know it's a judgment about what meets
the previously developed land
um definition and in some ways that
definition is quite restrictive so
things like Agricultural and
Horticultural land is automatically
Exempted from that definition
um and there are no doubt other sites
which fail on the you know minimum five
capacity type thing as well I I would
personally my honest advice is that I
don't think you we can turn the brown
for register into a list of every
Brownfield site in the entire District
because it needs to be looked at in the
lens of just those regulations so I mean
my suggestions Council Steptoe was that
we look at it in a kind of twin-tracked
way you have the brown for register
which is essentially our response to the
regulations and then we have the wider
work of the committee which is to look
at sites that may or may not meet those
meet their accounts be on the register
but warrant further examination as part
of the local plan that would be my
advice I I you know we've considered all
the sites that have been put to us and
this is where we've got to when we've
applied the regulations
that's right
um I believe this work should be done
through a working party hence I still
wish to move in and then this third
do you have a setting door for that
comes from Foster
you want to speak no they want me to be
speaking to the amendment now
okay
okay if anybody wants to speak now speak
to the amendment Council in Newport
just uh aquarium on this if if this item
is deferred now if or if if this item
wasn't deferred and this I and we
um to adopted this round for register
ever working group was formed to look at
the others this register could just
simply be updated with the findings of
that working group is that correct
uh well I would agree I mean there's a
requirement to update it at least
annually there wouldn't be an issue with
up essentially publishing it if you like
next week if if that's what if members
were happy to note it and then
subsequently agreeing an additional
update in September let's say October
whenever it might be so that's that is
something we could do that would
essentially meet the requirement for an
annual update and still accommodate what
members are requesting I think
that would meet the requirements of the
regulations as far as I see in terms of
the annual at least annual update
absolutely
yeah um
sorry it's just the questions we throw
in there which makes it more difficult I
I think the issue is that we are if we
put a
we put out a Brownfield register which
could be substantially changed within a
few months that doesn't look too good I
think there is no reason why I work in
party could not meet
within the next month
to do this for public occasionally in
September I've got concerns
I'm sure they're I absolutely agree with
councilor Walden Council the Steptoe
there are probably sites missing which
sound quite substantial
but there are also sites on here which I
I know
since this was done just aren't
available now they're not might be small
but they're just not there they're not
happening
um and I've got concerns around how
others
have been put on the register as well so
I think there's three different types of
concerns we've got and I think it's
quite important we address them I think
a working party is flexible can meet
quite quickly and can sort this out it's
not as though that we're not guessing
that science Council steptime Council
will know the sites they're talking
about I know the sites I'm talking about
I'm sure other members will know theirs
as well okay I'd like to speak on this
one about me
um sounds a lot
a thousand
which will need to be judged by quite a
complex set of criteria
how far have you looked at that list of
a thousand or so in terms of the rules
um
because
if we're pushing to meet
the local plan
putting it forward for you if the
opportunity is another exercise now
um I'm a little bit concerned if we go
through this exercise and find that you
know none or very few of them meet the
criteria
um so has there been any sort of
analysis look at looking at them in
terms perhaps you advise us in
yeah most certainly chairman
um I believe that uh Daniel mentioned
the PDL previously developed land and
the criteria behind it which I'm happy
to actually describe what that is is
land which is or was occupied by a
permanent structure including the
cartilage of the developed land although
it should not be assumed that the whole
of the kurtlish should be developed and
any Associated fixed surface
infrastructure this excludes land that
is or was last occupied by agricultural
of Forestry buildings land that has been
developed for mineral extraction or
waste disposal by landfill
where provision for restoration has been
made through development management
procedures
land in build-up areas such as
residential Gardens parks recreation
grounds and allotments and land that was
previously developed but where the
remains of the permanent structure or
fixture surface structure have blended
into the landscape so there's quite a
large remit within the PDL
where all of these that I wish to bring
forward include
and they haven't been and I feel they do
require further examination and I I
listen to what counts the steps I said
in regards to a couple of the items that
he was bringing through on concrete
bases
and I believe that it also comes into
PDL as well
okay so you've applied a degree of
assessment yourself I did and you're
confident that this
these a significant number of these will
meet the test yes okay
foreign
I think the only thing chairman is we
just need whatever conversation we
ultimately have which is fine about
about potential alternative sites we
just have to be guided by what I said
earlier which is are they available and
are they broadly suitable and obviously
um
as is expanded in part of the report
where you've got for example PDO sites
in the Greenbelt for example then it
gets quite complicated around openness
and things like that so
I think if we do continue a conversation
about potential return additional sites
to be included I think we just need to
be guided by those principles because
that is ultimately what we're going to
have to come back and demonstrate
through this kind of medium Okay so
you've read out the
technical definition of what counts and
what doesn't count and so on this issue
of whether it's available or not have
you got any
uh information on on that on these to
the best of my knowledge all of these
sites have been put forward
as sites on on the register
and they would be available and bearing
in mind this is the the Crux of the
matter is that we're looking at
Brownfield sites first
no matter what we're doing we we want to
avoid as much green belt as we possibly
can we are not going to avoid using
Greenbelt but we want to use as little
as we can this is what has been said in
in the studies that have come up they
want residents want us to use Brownfield
site first and they want to see
infrastructure
and so I'm only following what our
residents are asking us to do and
examine that because you know there's a
large number here there's just short of
2000 bearing in mind what I've
discovered and what was actually there
so you know that's that's a considerable
amount now it may be whittled down to
look at but I don't think it'll be
whittled down by that much it might come
out to 1500 but 1500 is a considerable
amount of units to go on to Brownfield
sites around the district which will
save us taking Brown uh taking uh
Greenbelt Land
yeah I'm I'm still a little bit
concerned that um you say these are on
the register they are that suggests to
me that we would have looked at them
and come to a conclusion to some extent
on those
um they would have been looked at and
the degree of conclusion would have
um
been made which is why they don't appear
presumably so what I'm concerned about
is we tear off into an exercise that
actually doesn't yield very much I'm not
saying we should redo it I agree with
the Brownfield philosophy
um but I'm just at a point where if
they're on the register they've been
looked at we're going to have a second
look at them second guess them and I
noticed Yvonne's art are asked to speak
so please speak yeah thank you chair um
just to
um basically underline what the chairman
is saying is that
um if these sites have been made
um
put in front of the planning policy team
for consideration as you say Council
Ward
um then one would assume that
that criteria as to whether or not they
should be on the Brownfield register or
not has actually that exercise has been
performed
councilor thank you no I believe there's
been an error and those errors need to
be corrected
it's as simple as that I believe that
there's been an error they have been in
the call for sites
and they have not been adjudged in my
opinion correctly
so I chairman I've indicated to speak
about three times now yes why you go put
your bike on you
yeah just very simply to to get to the
bottom of this
Council gold said they are we're in the
call for sites has an officer seen them
and rejected them
when how can we see that I don't I think
with there's a lot of people saying we
assume or presume but if we don't know I
think they need to be looked at
10.
yeah thank you so um in terms of
standard assessment when we're putting
together the round for register and to
be fair the first register was done when
the call for site sorry compartment I
don't want to go down the wrong rabbit
hole
Council of all said he's
given to office as a list I think I'm
not mistaken in saying that if I'm sure
Council will correctly have they studied
that list and projected the list
so we have looked at all the call for
sites submitted and we've come to the
Judgment we have that's not to say that
there aren't Brownfield elements of
sites in the course sites that aren't on
here but the nature of the cool Society
is that it's predominantly Green Dot
land it's predominantly agricultural
land it might have Farms with a
commercial element and things like that
but generally speaking to go for some
national conversations is not rich with
brown food sites so we we will have
looked at it I'm happy through any
process to re-visit our conclusions but
that's what we would have looked at I
think it comes back to that point and I
appreciate I'm repeating myself but it
comes back to that point about maybe
there's a separation down the line
between what fits the brown for register
perfectly and what needs to be some kind
of supplementary list of preferred Brown
food sites that maybe don't fully meet
the letter of the regulations that's
possibly the solution I can offer and it
I guess it would achieve the same thing
we're looking to do
through
um this ongoing piece of work
okay uh sorry councilor Foster
thank you chairman I would like to see
both sets of lists
before we go public with the Brownfield
register frankly
okay thank you okay uh sorry Mike yeah
we've got to go one excuse me I was
going to go one stage slightly further
um you've we've been talking about sites
that have been put in uh suggested sites
what I'm thinking is that I know of a
couple of sites and I don't know whether
they've been put in or not uh frankly no
idea but should we not
um be looking at sites ourselves and
identifying potential sites that may be
considered as Brownfield that have not
necessarily been put forward for
whatever reason perhaps the land owner
was away on holiday I don't know for
whatever reason but I think there are
potentially sites that we need to
perhaps look at and identify and say
that could potentially be a Brownfield
site whether or not it's been in the
system
I think that would make more sense and
you know if we suddenly look at all the
Brownfield sites and say well okay there
isn't any more so we start looking at
the green bill
but we haven't taken those other ones
into account I think the public would
perhaps be criticizing us for not
actually identifying science ourselves
okay well um I too have a have a view on
this
brownfield's very valuable
so I think we should put the effort into
looking at
the list
I think Mike's idea to go looking for
Brownfield sites are five years after we
did issues and options there's been
plenty of
opportunities for those sites to come
forward in that five years I think
that's pushing the envelope a lot
to to actually do that but
it is so
valuable Brownfield if there's anywhere
near a decent proportion of those that
passed the test
um that I think we should look at them
um in Sample but it's gonna have to be
done very quickly in a workshop in
August
and we've got to work until we finished
it because you're pushing for an earlier
finish I'm pushing down hard on all
these other things he's got to do so if
we are going to take the time out to do
that then we need to do that efficiently
and quickly and
that's my view so that needs to be put
in some
I mean I'm saying the same as you Daniel
you're willing to look at it but I'm I'm
being the project manager and say yeah
but I don't want to go wandering off a
month doing this I want to Crunch it and
it's either right or it's wrong
and if it yields and balances
significant Brownfield sites it would
have been worth it if he doesn't I'll be
very disappointed shall I say
thank you thank you chair I think that
the only thing I'd quickly say is coming
back on Council steptoe's point was
around
um thinking about other sites that
haven't been put in I think
fundamentally sites have to be available
and I appreciate there might be a role
for the council if you think about Town
Center regeneration in encouraging sites
to come forward but I guess we have done
call for sites over many years and
obviously when you've got brownford
sites in the urban area and if we're
being honest about the value of housing
everything else
they may well have come forward for
planning permission if they were
planning application if they were
already available so I think we have to
be slightly careful notwithstanding this
exercise that we're that we're looking
to do but as a more General point I
think we have to be slightly careful
about starting to scope in lots of
Brownfield sites that there's no
indication they're available
um because ultimately if they're not
available for development you know I.E
they're being used for a very profitable
commercial use or something then
um fundamentally that an inspector is
not going to allow us to allocate them
because that's going to be the first
question is is this site available for
development and landowners have had
years like Council says years to
put sites in the call for sites or make
planning applications so unless it's a
very recently vacated site
they're probably not available at the
moment that would be my guess so that
that's the only thing I would say is I
think we might just have to be slightly
realistic about whether site land is
available or not and we and we can't
really just assume
okay then thank you
that's my new report hey chairman um
sorry I'm a bit lost for words on this
but oh on
there are some potential
anomalies on here which
how Daniel how would I challenge well
I've got a couple of entries on here
that
um we've got Timber Grove which was
granted planning permission but is it
now that because that planning
permission has expired that that's why
the entry says
um not permissioned I think it says on
here yeah not permissioned but it has
had planning permission on it in my time
on the council anyway
um and then we've got another one
on here Rock 44 Land north of hambrow
Hill
and
that site
only had permission granted for car
storage I wouldn't really deem that as a
Brownfield site and it's just
basically a car park and what I've
mentioned to you earlier is that
something that we could just remove from
there because I don't really see that
being a Brownfield site so
I do it I would like to sorry
I would like to just challenge that let
down come back please yeah thank you so
just to pick up that latter Point
um first so
um I think on that site so that site has
come through the call for sites and I
think our judgment on it was that
there's a core in the site that has um
equestrian use which isn't Exempted by
the agricultural part of um the PDL
um definition as well as the car use so
we judged on balance that we thought
there's probably a core of Brownfield
land on there that might be able to
support some housing I mean it's a
judgment ultimately any planning
application because it's in the green
belt it clearly would have the trade-off
openness and may well determine
something different but that was a
judgment so
I I don't I wouldn't agree that it's not
Brownfield but you know it's a judgment
as to whether or not it's suitable for
development and you know and you could
challenge it on that grounds I suppose
if you had a different view about that
um about that specific thing in terms of
Timber Grove my understanding of Ronald
correct me if I'm wrong but although it
had a resolution to Grant permission
that committee it actually never had a
106 sorry section 106 sign so
technically the planning permission has
never been issued and so for all intents
purposes we've said not permissioned
because actually that 106 might never be
signed so
um that's just I think we've probably
put it in the longer term window on the
basis that
um clearly it's been agreed at point in
time it's got development potential but
it's unlikely to come forward tomorrow
because obviously the 106 is
um
unsigned I suppose is the only thing I
could say
okay
um it was me pushing to get this
Brownfield listing out
um that got it onto this this agenda but
as I said look I'm sorry Mike yeah
you're right Mike
was raised a couple of items which
The View was on one of them we shouldn't
come here I agree about the land of
north of Cambro here I've looked into
that I think some of us probably had
emails from a resident about that as
well and it to me doesn't look like it
makes the criteria for
for Brownfield and if we're talking
about particular items not to go on here
um
Roc 41
which is
in holbridge site planning permission
seven dwellings that is just not
happening they've revised the playing
commission for two new tax houses and
now they've they're not even doing that
it's just gonna they're just doing the
Bungalow again nothing Yvonne will know
about that one as well they're just
telling the band grow as it was so it's
it's not changed at all
okay I'd like to push this to some sort
of conclusion really I think there's so
many of them it seems that sitting and
talking about them individually here
isn't going to work okay
um I was going to say right at the end
of this meeting that
in my opinion
in the last period has not been enough
planning permittee
planning commit policy committee
meetings and I've already been
negotiating some more regular meetings
that are going to take place going
forward in fact I've already been
talking about a work a workshop or
already on a number of issues
um this one sounds like it would take
the workshop to do because of this year
number so I think we should move to
accept Ian's idea of rationalizing that
list because the value of yielding a
load of Brownfield sites is particularly
valuable to us I think so we need to
knuckle down but that means every member
needs to attend so if you've got the odd
0104 72 51 and 94 and you want to get
that ratified at the same time as Ian's
going for it a thousand
um then we need to order that meeting
and it's going to be tough because
that's a lot of ground to get through
and
I can't think of a better way of doing
it than putting people in a room and
crashing through that list to see what
we if we reach a point
where halfway through the period and
we've only ruffled up
a couple of legitimate
things I should be calling to stop to it
because we need to be testing this and
getting this done and hopefullying it's
going to yield enough to work that will
work the worth the effort
for somewhere or another or he'll
probably need help we wrap this up in
terms of
there's a
recommendation on here yeah
thank you okay we've already had a
motion to defer this so I guess we have
to get a second
um and we we take a a vote on deferring
this
um
and that will include the code of seal
that that's based on a work a working
group and I'm saying in August and we
all have to attend
let's cancel sorry I think as you just
said I think it should go into the
motion the date we're doing this by and
to which committee we're expecting this
come back to so there is a time frame
for it so we all understand what we've
got to do and by when and the public
know that as well okay well we'll we'll
do the work come to the conclusion Dan
and his guys then are going to have to
bundle it up and represent it at the
next formal meeting so that's one of the
reasons I'm pushing this to get it done
in August
um and it will be one one shot at it to
get it done
um
if that's acceptable then we need to
vote on a motion to defer it subject to
a workshop to make sure we've caught all
the brownfields that's available
it's all those in favor
yeah
okay synonyms
okay
um just for completeness I'm scheduling
item
I've had a couple of uh
emails from residents on particular
brownfields
one of them has been answered by the
officers directly in writing I just want
to assure the public
that the other outstanding one which uh
the last
part of which arrived at about five
o'clock tonight so I haven't had a
chance to talk to the
officers about it but that will be
responded in writing I would suggest
early next week
early next week that's in hand I'll just
sort of make that for completeness tell
you what what I'm doing because they
were addressed to me personally
okay
thank you members thank you for member
of the public for your patience
and see you at the workshop
meetings close at nine
27.